[Musique]
Henry Marionnet vit sur sa terre depuis
73 ans sa passion pour le vin il l'a
découvert à l'âge de 4 ans quand il app
porte à boire un ouvrier agricole dans
le chat de son père l'enfant Hume
longuement les effluves aujourd'hui
encore Henry se souvient de ses
premières
senteurs en remplissant la bouteille
j'ai senti les effluves du vin et que
j'avais 4 ans j'avais pas encore imaginé
ça et j'en prenais plein plein le nez et
j'ai eu une émotion vous voyez rien que
de d'en parler j'ai encore cette émotion
j'ai eu une émotion tout un frisson dans
dans dans dans dans le dos et j'ai dit
mais c'est merveilleux et voilà je suis
devenu vigron à partir de ce
jour-là soin en Sologne un paysage une
terre ou plutôt deux celle du bas
sableuse là où existait à l'air tercière
une mer la mer des falins et puis la
terre du haut argileuse et pierreuse
difficile à travailler pourtant depuis
l'époque gauloise le paysage est habité
et modifié par les agricultures
nouvelles la famille marionnaet
apportera sa contribution en créant un
paysage viticole c'est mon père qui a
qui a fait les premières vignes
effectivement disons qu'avant du temps
de mes grands-parents il y avait surtout
de l'élevage des il y avait des vaches
par ici bon c'était complètement
différent mon père avait planté de la
vigne mais pas partout parce que à
l'époque on pouvait la TER était
tellement difficile à travailler que Mme
avec les chevaux on n'arrivait pas à
rentrer la charrue dans dans dans dans
le sol
donc il y avait quelques parcelles qui
n'avaient pas été planté et moi j'ai
tout tout planté complètement de 1967 à
1978 Henry replante et agrandit passant
de 20 à 62 hactares le domaine est
planté majoritairement de Gamet noir à
jus blanc pour les vins rouges et de
sauvignon pour les vins blancs mais
Henry ne s'arrête pas là ce qu'il aime
c'est chercher expérimenter ah moi j'ai
eu une chance extraordinaire dans la vie
j'ai pas fait d'école de viticulture
j'ai rien fait et quand j'ai démarré j'y
connaissais rien du tout à part que mon
père était
vigneron et j'avais vu un peu comment se
passait les choses mais il avait jamais
fait de vin rouge il avait bon bref tout
son vignob était obsolè il a fallu
démarrer à zéro et
créer j'ai fait l'expérimentation un
beau jour en 1992 de planter un hectare
de vigne de gamé non greffé comme
c'était au au 18e siècle et au 17e
siècle Enfin auparavant et à la première
écolle que j'ai faite j'ai vu tout de
suite que le vin avait été de meilleure
qualité c'était la classe
au-dessus cette expérimentation est
payante repérée par Go et mot la maison
marionnaet gagne en notoriété Henri
encouragé continue à chercher vin
naturel sans sulfite et cette
vinification il obtient des prix dont un
premier prix pour son Sauvignon nominé
parmi les meilleurs sauvignons du monde
connu et reconnu Henry est invité à
développer des vignobles et des vins
jusqu'au Chili où il partira quelques
semaines par an mais comme il aime à le
dire j'ai toujours vécu ici et j'ai bâti
ma maison juste devant la maison de mes
parents à 100 m de la maison de mes
parents c'està-dire que dans la vie j'ai
fait 100 m c'est ma terre j'en changerai
jamais j'y suis attaché je vous dirais
pas je connais chaque caillou qui qui
qui a dans cette vigne mais presque je
dirais pas que c'est le plus beau
terroir du monde loin de là non mais
c'est le mien Henry attaché à sa terre
passionné par la culture du vin
participe à la création de ces paysages
si particuliers que sont des territoires
viticoles particulier car le raisin tout
d'abord alimentaire est ici transcendé
dans une culture du plaisir que
l'antiquité nous a
légué